i come out of church on sunday i'm ready
to let's go put some things in practice
this week let's be
let's see if we can really apply these
things some lessons i've learned
and i'm good for monday i'm solid on
tuesday i'm solid on wednesday starts to
fade a little bit on thursday a little
bit more on friday ooh
saturday come on sunday i need you again
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense my guest today
is matthew mcconaughey you know one of
the words that comes through big time in
the interview is
is humility this word that he's tried to
embody in a healthful balance that's not
sort of like humble head down not me
confident and humble he has a new book
called green lights
you gotta listen all the way to the end
of the interview because
um i asked him what his next green light
is
his answer you'll have to wait and hear
it but his
answer i think is sometimes what we all
need to realize
is our next green light you've been busy
on these podcasts huh
i i have been yeah um
for about six weeks now seven weeks
probably
wow i'm so curious like that i'm first
thing i thought was i was like man
you've been doing a ton of these is it
is it because you like them or is it
just
part of the new scope of how you promote
something
well i thought i would like them because
they're long form i do like a long form
better than
having to you know fit something in five
minutes snippets
um and then the book's
doing well and when it's doing well i'm
like i didn't think i'd still be doing
zooms for it now i didn't have anything
so i said i'm going to stay on this
train as long as it's
as the books are selling so um that's
the funny thing about books is that if
you're not promoting it they just they
don't sell
as much right yeah it's my first time
into this i mean i will say
there's when we can go back and
re-engage again
i'm i'm doing this i prefer this 95
of the time the other morning i was on a
zoom in italy at 8 am i was on a zoom in
the uk at nine i was on a zoom in new
york at 10
at 11 and a zoom in la at um
11 so yeah italy at 8
uk at nine uh new york at ten
la at eleven and then the 11 o'clock is
over at 11 59
i say goodbye and at 12 noon i'm having
lunch live
with my family in texas i'm not going i
couldn't have done that
there's no way there are good things
that have come from this year
yeah and i think you know there's this
a lot of the whole world's gonna we are
living in the future i think
a little bit i think some people are not
going to go back and fully engage
i mean yeah we've got things here my
mom's with us she's 88
so she gets to see your grandkids every
day for the last eight months that would
have happened
you know kids are doubling down on sort
of creative projects that they wouldn't
have taken the time to do if they were
back in school
um the ones getting a little
self-reliance i hope you know
they'll have they've all they've got a
souvenir 2020 will be a souvenir a
little tattoo
for them for the rest of their life you
know so it is kind of interesting to
think how
all of this will affect kids because
even something simple like seeing my
sister she has three little girls and
seeing them with like masks on
and um just the whole experience like
what kind of imprinting are they gonna
have from that aspect
and then also from the other side of it
which is like a lot of
you know home time family time
connection like
like i feel like you know my sister and
like probably every parent you have to
get creative
and how you're gonna even just spend
time
having fun and also how to teach them
like everybody's a teacher now it's
it's that generation i'm super curious
what
how this is gonna how this is gonna
shape them
you know our kids have been born into an
affluent situation with me and camilla
in a lifestyle
a little little little uh hardship that
was non-negotiable
pretty good pretty good deal pretty i
think it'll be a pretty good deal
you know um and i mean i have a lot of
fri
a lot of parents that are friends of
mine that that's their biggest worry oh
my gosh it just breaks my heart for my
kids they can't see the difference
and my gut is yeah i get i get it's hard
but i i
they're they're more resilient than me
we're giving them credit for i mean
this'll i think they're going to be be
fine
in some ways i think my kids will miss
some of the intimacy that we've had
the two meals a day that we sit down and
say
grace before where we used to maybe just
only do one a day and that was dinner
or the self-reliant hey you set your set
your own alarm cook your
own breakfast and you know to handle
your school stuff and about that
intimidating at first but now they're
doing it like it's clockwork
so i don't know i'm a big i'm a bit i
love self-reliance too
and i think yeah i think i like i don't
think you can get too big of doses of
that too early
but you said i don't think some people
are gonna come back from this in the
same way like some people aren't coming
back
what do you mean by that um well i think
what i mean by that is the way
i think people their relationship with
the rest of the world especially
i think business has changed forever um
i think where before cobit if you and i
this was our meeting it kind of meant
one of us was dissing the other like oh
it wasn't
important enough for us to do it in
person you know but now
we've done it it's become the norm so
the taboo off of saying hey let's
remotely speak is off and we were going
to go yeah
meet you tomorrow except simcall or
whatever that call whatever that is
um and it's not dissing someone it's the
new norm i think
the companies are seeing how that
actually a lot of companies are actually
doing
better now that their employees are
working from home
they're seeing that that employees are
more adaptable um
like my blind right now is sort of okay
we've proven
right now that you got 5g
go live wherever you want to on the
planet
in the rain forest if you want go where
go to whatever mountaintop if you can
get 5g you can be wherever you want to
be
at any time um in that way i don't think
that way i think it will it will have
changed and a lot of people are going to
say once we can go back and
be physically be in the same place again
a lot of people are going to go nothing
i'm good i like i prefer this
um i think about kind of the energetics
of it too and just how
i feel like there's so much polarizing
happening with
there's so many people that are like
really into the fear and
really concerned and then there's sort
of like a growing distance between that
and you know the other landing spot
which is i'm just
you know it's not part of my reality
like it's not my daily thoughts i don't
revolve around it i'm not really
like i'm kind of describing the way i
think about i'm just
i don't really try and participate i'm
not participating i'm just
i'm playing into it as much as i need to
to do what i want to do without
any extra thought or energy and then
just like
i don't know not watching the news and
there's also that energetic
split too of like not coming back and
i'm kind of curious
about which yeah um
well and then you know it was the
perfect storm this year
you know i mean you got covered you've
got social unrest you've got it all in
an election year
at a time when we were sitting here
going i
really need to does anyone have a
consensus on who we can listen to
who's on the group where everyone's
going not him not her
not that place not this meditation not
that and you're all going oh geez so i
got to work it out myself
and you know i think the private sector
all the way down to the individual has
more power and influence
self-determination than ever before
right now i think
i think our leaders and even politics
have a whole lot of
redefining and declaring to do i think
that's a broken business and going like
i
we've learned okay i don't most of us
don't trust that we're still in the
midst of distrusting that right now
um in in in our country you know um
yeah i mean i've tried to lean into
you know look this right here in some
ways you go
well it's not as intimate we're not in
person i don't know i got a pretty good
picture of you right now
in some ways is this more intimate
because
you're in your house i didn't come you
and i didn't travel to a studio
to go sit down meet certain handlers go
hang out in a green room
do hair and makeup meet a bunch of
people all set up to just have you and i
sit down and someone go
action but now i meet you you're you're
home
i'm in my home you see my background i'm
talking with you here we didn't have to
travel we didn't have to
handle a bunch of other stuff i i walked
up i just said
hug my kid 35 seconds before i am on the
phone
on a zoom in a call with you that's
pretty cool
and quite intimate so
it kind of makes me think of this whole
like diminishing returns on your
investment of time
like we're getting it done we're
connecting but we're
also able to do so many other things and
such
close time proximity there's an intimacy
with i can kind of see
the palm tree in your backyard you know
you're you're
in my office with me you know it's
interesting
you know i think that it does it has
created time
to spend more time doing what
maybe we should value more that we never
gave ourselves to time to value more
i mean we've been forced to be on top of
family
and that ain't always easy but jesus
usually a pretty good thing to do by
hook or by crook you know
we've been you know we're we're petting
the pets longer
we're spending time maybe a little more
time with ourselves
as well which is always i think a good
thing
um yeah so it's been a forced winter and
yeah tragic for
so many um disruptive but there's good
there's good things that come out of
the disruption you know you had time to
sit down and
reread all your journals and write a
book
yeah i actually wrote it before the code
came
um and was in the process of editing it
um but yeah sure i've had more time to
i've been writing more like once
in this last eight months you know um
finalizing
this book thinking about what's the next
the next book that i want to write
what's it going to be about how is it
connected to green lights how is it not
how's it separate how's it different
it'll have a thread of connection but
being on eight weeks of touring the book
i've
been able to crystallize some ideas and
evolve some ideas that were in
green lights the book into oh there's
the next chapter of that
approach um you know that's been
pretty cool but i but i'm i'm so i mean
maybe because of my job
i'm told i'm pretty adaptable that i'd
like you tell me
you tell me i got to stay home i'm like
oh
cool thank you okay great i got stuff
too
um and i know it's not as easy for for
some people but i'm like
like i said it started off the call in
some ways i will maintain
ways that i go about my daily life even
after i'm free to roam
yeah somewhere i'll maintain what i've
changed uh during code
well i think what comes across like as
i'm
preparing for this and i've got your
book and i'm
watching things and i got picked up the
book and within
the fir within the intro i have
three pages of legal pad notes i'm like
every
paragraph there's uh a question i want
to ask every page has something quotable
like it's just so dense of information
and such uh such depth and such
insight and such experience and opinions
and i i i had to stop like i had to stop
reading it because i just kept
writing like i just kept writing no
i was like i'm not i'm not i want to
read this
i want to just read this like a regular
person
instead of reading this to talk to you
so i just stopped and i kind of was like
man i felt like i owed it to you to read
the book
and i realized that like in in this sort
of like dynamic i was having i was like
what comes across so clearly is that um
you have been so
willing and able and successfully
able to evolve like your evolution you
don't get to the point of writing a book
like this and having the information you
do and doing the commencement speeches
you do
and interviews and you know speeches
without having lived it learned it
and have that depth and that's what i
that's what i want to
talk about is is just where did that
willingness to evolve come from as you
just said about like hey
covet happens i've decided these things
probably aren't going to change for me
and if it does then i'll adapt to that
too but where like where does that
a willingness to evolve come from
that bravery essentially since one of
the things that knows when we write the
book
is that same damn questions that i was
interested in
and look at life who am i in it where am
i going what are we doing
what's about responsibility what's about
hate what do you give a damn about what
do you not give a damn about
i was asking the same questions at 14 as
i am now at 51.
my questions have evolved and my answers
i've had some answers but it's not too
many of those questions but
it hasn't made for fewer questions
um the i've always been curious
and about investigating
who the heck i am and what's my
relationship with the world
what's my relationship with my past the
book
i've never had a great relationship with
my past i'm a guy that's like boom next
i don't even like watching all my i
don't even like watching my movies i
like making my movies a lot more like
watching them i don't even i don't even
like to go back i don't listen to any
podcast i do nothing i don't like
hearing my voice i just i do it
and let someone else tell me how it was
well then i go back in the book and i'm
like oh geez man i'm going to look back
i'm going to see things i was
embarrassed about
ashamed of i'm going to see an arrogant
little ass
to where i was a cocky little s.o.b and
i went back and looked at it and all
those things were true
but i found that most things i was
embarrassed about i actually
laughed at most of the things i was
ashamed about i said uh i forgive you
for that or already forgave myself for
it and i and then i also saw that
arrogant little sob
a few times where i was a little mr
know-it-all
but that read to notice that oh if you
wouldn't have been so arrogant at that
point
you wouldn't have had the confidence to
put yourself in the position to get
humble
so good on you for being an arrogant sob
at that time
um i just do to investigate
myself i think i think that it can be
true and then on some extent it's true
everybody was i mean
why not really get to know as well as
you can the one person
that you're stuck with no matter what
the ones it's the one person you can't
the one person you're sleeping with
every night no matter who's in the bed
you know why not shake hands with that
person and go
sometimes it's a bloody wrestling match
you know and sometimes
i write about a lot of my times in
solitude it's not fun
i'm not enjoying the company me and
we're gonna have it out it's like put on
the helmet strap in the seatbelt this is
gonna get rough
and it's just me and me but usually i'll
get to a point where i go okay
as i said when i'm saying that looking
back at the past all right
you know let's forgive yourself for this
and let's say the buck stops here we're
not doing that anymore i'm not putting
up with that part
of who you are matthew and let's move on
because hey
the one person i can't get rid of we
better figure out how to get along
and i don't know that that journey i
feel like i can know other people
better i think we can all know other
people
trust other people believe in other
people better if we trust and believe
and know ourselves better
well we can't meet anyone at a level
that we haven't
achieved we can't love anyone
greater than what we love ourself we
can't understand
the aspects of humans until we've
seen it in ourselves right you you're
defining um something that i've been
working on for years
and will continue working on the
generosity
of selfishness you just said it and you
can't do any of those things unless you
do them for yourself
take the bible jesus says what's the
what's the what's the one you want to
take with the bible if you take
any of them love thyself as love you
love thy neighbor as thyself
gotta bring it and so today we go oh
that's narcissistic oh my god you're
egomaniac but no
no no no there's a version of selfish i
understand
that that is for me but not
for anyone else but the selfish you and
i are talking about the one you just
defined
is actually saying no the one the dude
it's the
it's the uh um what they say on the on
the on the plane
if we lose cabin pressure yeah over your
own face person you won't be able to
help someone else out
your child whoever what are some things
that
you have realized have been part of you
um what's the words you use the
generosity of your selfishness
what are some things that uh you've come
to make peace with
that um have transformed your
view about this all something you do
different something you added in
something you do for yourself that you
know
allows you to have the space and
understanding to give it back
give give more getting my sleep i'm a
nine and a half hour night
hopefully and and so
she will get up and do something things
in the morning earlier than me
and she says no
i'd rather get up earlier than be around
you with less than nine and a half hour
sleep
go back to bed go back to bed i've got
this
go to sleep i'm not going to be around
you today that's the nine and a half
hours right
um or my time in solitude she's been
very good at being someone who
kind of can tell when my spider senses
are going i i
i need to go get on the frequency again
i need to go get some quiet time i need
to go get away from all the noise i need
to hear myself think and
form form some opinion chill
the same time or even before or come up
to me and go
i think you need a little road trip with
the y-o-u
and i'll be like yeah i think you're
right she goes get out get out of here
and and and then and of course does the
beautiful thing of going like
don't call me nothing like that and of
course if you tell a man not to call you
and it's okay we're gonna call you all
the time
i have definitely made that mistake i
would i
i'm curious about this sort of the 21
day trips you do do you do them every
year
it's not like a scheduled basis how'd
they start they started
um by a particular very particular treat
as dreams go ahead of what seemed to be
a contradictory geography
there was two things that i knew i had
the dream once in 1990
two i think and then i had and i
remember waking up from it and the irony
of the dream wasn't lost on me but i was
like that was weird
four years later i had the exact same
dream i mean the exact same frames in my
mind the dream lasted
the exact same amount of time and the
outcome was the same so
then i went i immediately knew when i
woke up that is the exact same dream i
had two years ago
okay now somebody somewhere she's
telling me something i got something i
got to follow here so what you know then
you go
what do i know from the dream well two
things i knew
was that i was on the amazon river and
the banks of the river
all the way out through the horizon was
lined with african tribesmen
so i go to the atlas of africa looking
for the amazon river
well as you know you can look forever
and you're not going to find it because
it's the wrong continent the amazon's in
south america but in my dream
those are the two things i know go down
there with a camp along and float the
amazon so i packed up my bag and i go
and it was a 22-day trip i come back and
ah
i fulfilled the dream i got it i learned
that's a lot of which
a lot of what's in the book came from
the journals i kept on that trip down to
uh um
in south american peru great
now cut to 99 three years later
i have the exact same dream again frame
for frame same outcome and i wake up all
night going
whoa okay this must be meaning that i
need to chase the second half of the
dream
which were the african tribesmen
so now i'm going well africa is a mighty
big continent where am i supposed to go
after a couple days sitting around just
kind of going let it come to you
figure it out i was listening to one of
my favorite musicians ali farkatore and
i'm like oh he's african where's he from
pulled out the liner notes family from
nia funke mali
i'm like well there's my cup there's my
coordinate there's my dot on the map i'm
going to go find ali and see where the
trip takes
so i got a ticket to uh uh obamacare the
capital of mali
hitchhiked nine and a half hours to this
little river trading town called uh um
what was it uh mopty
yeah well i'm mostly only hanging on the
side of a
a bus um and then met up
met a guy who spoke some broken english
i said i want to go find ali next day we
were on a boat headed up river four days
later found ali
um and then was like well i don't know
where to go now i found my
that's the only point on the map i had
was to come find him and now i found him
and we had lunch together and uh hung
out
and then that was over and i was like
what i do now and the guide goes
there's a place i think you need to see
and i took his lead and we went further
up north and went hiking through the
bonji agar for another
18 days and and then that finished
off that dream and there's some great
stories uh as you keep reading in there
from from that trip so
that finished the dream i have not had
the dream again i did go
back though to molly unannounced
showed up on that guide my friend now
isabello showed up on his
door at his door um five and a half
years later
and said let's do the same trip and we
went back and saw
all the same villages where all the kids
were five and a half years older
every adult i met was five and a half
years older and did the exact same
exact same trip for 22 days why'd you go
back
why'd you go back because that's a place
where i felt more at home than i've ever
anywhere i've ever felt you know i don't
know i don't know if you ever have these
feelings but sometimes i have a feeling
that you're in a you know you have that
feeling if you're in a place you're like
i've been here
i've been here before is this deja vu or
vue deja
you know coming or going i'm not sure
but it was one of those places where i
was like okay i felt
uh it really didn't
that place baselines me more than
anywhere else
wow it really really baselines me and uh
um
had some wild coincidences over there
that also were like
okay i heard that you know coincidences
or
exactly you would call them that i don't
i would i don't i think that would
be not giving them enough credit i'm
really
curious as you're going through the
story and these
coincidences and these dreams and these
signs
you know being from texas and
having them i would imagine a much more
religious background in a little more
conventional sense
and then going on these explorations not
only
outside of sort of texas and the states
and whatever else
but inside and it feels like there's
not a way you can avoid
a level of spirituality in this
journey so where do you land with all
that
um well
i land with
that there is no landing spot
i land with you know i would consider
myself an optimistic mystic
now i
i believe there's many paths to the same
destination i
don't believe that it's over
when someone's reading our eulogy and
we're in our cask
in this life um so
what that is is you know we'll find out
hell i don't know that's for sure
nobody knows that's what's so fun about
it
um i um
you know i land with that as is
what's my relationship what's the music
i'm putting out
and what's the reverb coming back you
know soul's intention it's so it's feels
so
sound you know when what we put out what
our soul puts out
sort of comes boomerangs right back to
us from the world i'm like
yes that's what i was that's the music i
was that's the you picked up the beat
and threw it right back at me and it's
one long song we're singing
in this life or beyond um
i uh um you know as far as relationship
with
um my relationship with with god
it's uh i had a real i had real trouble
with that
word humility and being humble for most
of my life
i didn't know i i i misinterpreted it i
think for so long
in that i didn't know how to have
confidence while i was so humble like
humble walk would be kind of
that false mop which is complete yes
and actually arrogant and condescending
and it's in its inverted way
you know um and when i heard a
definition
that humility and being humble is about
admitting and knowing that you have more
to learn i went oh
now that i can purchase that i can still
stand
head high heart high shoulders back look
you in the eye
and carry forward and understand that
i've built things in my life and i'm
carrying them with me you know let's go
courageously into the future
um but until i got that little click of
what that word meant
uh you know my relationship
spiritually was sort of on and off on
and off a little bit more um
i do i've also also found this this is
another metaphor for i think not only my
relationship spiritually but a lot of
people's
i found that when i
put other things like my career
or or or you know uh
if when that's not the top of the ladder
that's not the number one
thing of my what i've got to achieve
when it moves down to two or three
behind say family and faith
i'm better at it
i get more results i win more
trophies uh you know when i lower it
down the echelon
um you know and you know
i've always thought about you can't sort
of throw that on just anybody because
you got to have a work ethic and you got
to be ambitious and you got to want it
right because you throw that on some but
some people are like oh that means i go
i kind of half-ass it i don't have to
really no no no no no
you don't have it you you actually you
you want it and want to do you do the
work to to get the results you want
as much or more but you're more focused
because it's
not what is going to give you solely
give you your identity
i mean so there's a humility in that
which is also about you know
um uh you know when you're number two
it's it's it's what i like about going
to
church i'm on sunday i need it's about
time
i come out of church on sunday i'm ready
to let's go put some things in practice
this week let's be
let's see if we can really apply these
things some lessons i've learned
and i'm good for monday i'm solid on
tuesday i'm solid on wednesday starts to
fade a little bit on thursday a little
bit more on friday ooh
saturday come on sunday i need you again
you know so so i i
i uh um you know i try to check in
um with a lot of gratitude my daily
practice is trying to be
full of gratitude and i'm and i believe
that actually gratitude can breed
responsibility which is what i believe
breeds
freedom that the more things you're
thankful for you're gonna have more
things that you're gonna tend to that
you're gonna give a damn about
that you're not gonna take for granted
that you're going to
maintain instead of just letting it
break and buying a new one
you know what i mean that you you
gratitude that breeds that
responsibility if you start taking
responsibility
i think that's the right
responsibilities lead to true to true
freedom it's this
getting to the giving part it's uh it's
um the gratitude it's sort of like the
selflessness but
were there some moments or stories that
you're like
were transformative for you where you
had an experience and it gave
you some a feeling an insight a
shift that you couldn't come back from
again
yes um and there's ones
that i've probably forgotten that at the
time i knew they were real and i said
don't you ever forget this
you know how it is that old truth lands
on us like a butterfly and a lightning
bolt at the same time
you know what i mean and you know it's
true and you know that it's timeless
and you know that it was true long
before you ever hear and it'll be true
long after you're gone so you better
hang on to it maintain that thing polish
it
but then the hard part comes now we got
to go re-enter
the rodeo of life in the coliseum
under thousands millions billions
oh how do i maintain my solitude walking
through this
slowly
that's where the rubber is on the road
right there that's right
love it love it rubber to the road i
mean that i mean i heard you talking
about that
where you know it's it's um that you
even considered that maybe you should be
a monk
and then is this true yeah
yeah i did that's a very interesting
thing to think you might
maybe should be yeah i thought you know
and i said it wasn't a fleeting thought
heck i still think about it it still
crosses my mind but
my good friend brother christian who is
a monk actually
talked to me and he was like i don't
think you should become a mom
why he goes you you
you you put it here to communicate you
need to be
out doing what you're doing you're here
to travel communicate and have
relationships with people
and create art things like that that
don't go take
that what you can be doing that that's a
gift you've got don't don't take that
away and come back and
just hermitize up you know um
but uh i mean i have a great
reverence for people who
commit their life to
god or commit their life to daily going
it's it
i'm if i want a daily stay in prayer i
want to daily see
you know god in every natural living
thing i want to daily see things that i
go oh that's of god i i reverence
and uh for for for people that
that commit themselves to that
this reminds me of um i interviewed jay
shetty um
a few weeks ago and maybe you've done a
podcast you've talked to him
he has a book called think like a monk
he used to be a monk and then that's
the same thing you need to go like you
need to get into the world you need to
not stay here you
are meant to get this message out so
then it leads me to wonder
it's a really you know what do you think
your purpose is
yeah what is what are you here to do
it's a great question i am asking myself
that all the time
um i'll bring up that word that
that just used a minute ago that brother
christian told me communicate
i mean i i could unpack that word in
many different ways for hours
um because of so many ways we do it and
and
and how we communicate with the
relationships that we have
in our life as i said earlier with our
past with our future with people with
places
uh with hopes with dreams with how do we
how do we you know what's our
relationship with failure
um um and how do we communicate that
those in
those with ourselves um how do we
deconstruct that
sort of how do we see the perspective
right there's a lot of things
perspective
um is is huge
um my purpose
well i know that this may not be the
answer but i'm
i'm a storyteller that's that's what i
always
when i first went to film school before
i ever started acting i just said i
remember saying i just want to be the
storytelling business
if i could make a living telling stories
how fun would that be how cool would
that be and to this day
20 30 years later i still consider
myself i'm in the storytelling business
um and if i can tell a story
in a way which i've been told i did so
in the book
that you can go oh that's more than just
a good story yes that was entertaining
absolutely but also it enlightened me in
this way
it educated me in this way it made me
think about myself
it gave me more questions and or
confidence or
made me say i'm going to reapproach this
thing um
i you know so
you know i i'm four stories being for
for entertainment
solely and there's great value in that
but i'd also i also like stories that i
can go
why can't i take something that into my
own life and i'm gonna go out and
give that a boot i'm gonna try that out
and see what that music is it comes back
to me
if a more true music comes back to me if
i apply that and take that
in the way that i see the world and the
way that i wake up in the morning the
way that i look my
wife in the eye first thing in the
morning the way i embrace my kids first
thing what
then what do i get back and
i usually find that you know and i don't
follow it all the time
but i'm still you know working on it as
i said i don't think i'm ever landing i
don't think we ever have a tada moment
um and i think that's the point um
but you know you you when you get that
reciprocity back to you
and you are catching green lights you
all feel like you are on your frequency
you are dancing
through the world you're taking the
tough stuff and you're dancing by it and
through it and handling you're taking
the good stuff with
grace and confidence and compounding
assets to the future
when that's happening and you're do
actually doing more
it's a very selfish
thing to experience because it feels
good people talk about charities
you know there's a selfish endeavor to
give
i selfishly feel great when a child at
our foundation
eyes light up and goes you're the one
you're the first person that's ever done
something for me that's not asking for
something back and you don't even know
me
why thank you that's a me feeling good
selfishly feels
good so again there are selfless acts
that can be very selfish and they're
selfish acts that could be very self
less at the same time um but i'm still
working on my
my my you know purpose as i said i don't
you know i think if we get if if
if more of us could get less result
oriented
at the same time have a result out there
i'm a big
i like writing the headline first and
then trying to live the story to the
headline you know i like that but i also
have had great satisfaction my life by
jumping off the cliffs and saying hell
i'm gonna have to figure out how to fly
on the way down
and it seems to be that life's a balance
of those two and both are a risk
though um so i don't know if i answered
your question about what my purpose is
but those are some
yeah you did i mean i mean yes and it's
your answer
anything that you answered that's true
to you right now is your truth it is
your answer
and it's welcome and it's totally okay
for it to evolve and change in fact it's
beautiful if it does
i think that shows uh uh
it shows that you're not rigid it shows
that you don't
um you're open to change
and so i think that that's probably
what's allowed you this
sort of space to evolve and um
as i said i think that's that's the
thing that came through the most is i
was like
you don't know about all this stuff
because you haven't said yes to evolving
and saying yeah i don't believe that
anymore
or i didn't believe it and guess what
it's come back around and now i see it
from
i see it with new eyes and
so but storytelling got me thinking
about um
about your movies and as a storyteller
are you
doing it through the movie you choose
the roles you choose or whatever it is
that you bring to that character like
i'm thinking about like
for for me i just as as as something i
have to say
i have three favorite movies um
contact lucy
and interstellar okay so that perhaps
give you an insight into my
sort of like yeah what i'm into
and we and we've we've just sure been
covering uh some contacts and some
interstellar
uh ideas here in the last 30 minutes and
so do you choose those roles because
that's sort of part of your storytelling
to be a part of those or how does it
work
well i mean it's kind of those for
instance those two choices are the two
of the two of those films that you just
mentioned in your top three that i've
been in
so i get famous
right after the time the kill comes out
overnight
in 48 hours it went from
before time to bill opened there's a
hundred scripts there i want to do man
i'll do any of them
99 no you can't one yes you can
over 48 hours in one weekend of a
successful big
blockbuster major studio hit like time
to kill was
it inverted monday morning after that
weekend time to kill open
it was those hundred scripts that were
99 those one yes we're now 99 yeses
one no and i was like wait a minute you
mean 48 hours ago i'd have done
any of these and i couldn't do any of
them and now you're telling me i can do
all of them and you want me to decide
so i took one of those trips that first
one
to peru cause i was like i gotta hear
myself think man you're asking me to
have some discernment
when now the world has opened up over me
and
my feet are feeling a little bit off the
ground understandably so
so i chose to do i think one of the next
movies i did was contact
and the reason was i've always been
interested in this uh um
i've always believed that science is the
practical pursuit of god
and there was this story and i was like
oh i want to be in the place of the
believer
to jody foster's science and
try to show that this is these are not
contradictions these are a paradox that
these two coexist um
which a lot of us still don't see see
that or believe that
um so i i remember thinking of that as a
philanthropic
choice i remember saying this is a story
that should be shared with the world if
i can be a part of this
is a good message to get out there oh
and i get to be
an actor and portray the side that i
lean towards
in the movie um it was the same reason
i've done amistad
i was like oh this is a piece of world
history in american history that should
be shared
and boy if you could you know a history
lesson packed in entertainment
not a not a not a old dusty book that
gets so damn
boring to learn the same facts and so
those were two like philanthropic
choices of personal
beliefs and stories i thought should be
shared
interstellar you know let me say this
here's what i
here's what i learned from contact i
remember writing this down it's in
one of the journals i remember finishing
contact and writing down
well god's backyard is bigger than i
thought
so we go to interstellar that's
years later and i was a father
at the heart of that story as a father
and his children specifically a father
and a daughter
and that great conflict of
what would you if you do what you were
born to do
which cooper was born to be an astronaut
a pilot
so he's that that was his purpose but
yet it means
you've got to leave abandon go chase
your dream but
miss the fatherhood part and be away
from your
kids especially your daughter for that
amount of years
would you do it it's a good it's great
would you do it's a great question
um and then the fact that christopher
nolan
who's so good at the epic expanse of
world and short of
when he's at his best goes from intimate
like heartfelt things like that
what i just told you a father and a
daughter which could be in an
independent movie
you know what i mean for no budget at
two this massive expanse of
epic scope uh
to go
i i always grew up thinking that that
you know i was only gonna i would be an
astronaut before
uh be a sailor before an astronaut
meaning like oh up there too far away
i'm not gonna think about it so i was
always that's the pragmatic side of me
everything's like well just deal
like it was i remember telling my dad at
fourteen i was like that i just like
you know if it's it i'm army before a
air force
you know what i mean i'm like i want to
deal with stuff on the ground right in
front of me i don't even i mean
that's it well something like contact
opens that up a little bit but then
interstellar opens it up which says oh
let's say there's other worlds up there
which we're finding out are becoming
more of a reality where we used to only
talk about the noon
moon now the moon sounds like oh that's
just down the road let's talk about mars
you know what i mean so we're reaching
out into this new frontier
and and you know talk about our futures
that seems to be where the next real
estate
is coming from out there you know so
likely is interstellar to be a reality
yeah right i don't know i mean
it's not not for me to say i don't know
but yeah so
that was just another one i thought it
was
i don't know if i thought it was
philanthropic i'm not saying that but i
thought it was like man this is a
big crystal in action film with
a lead who's a father at the heart and
father being the only thing i ever knew
i ever wanted to be in my life anyway
it's like i i'd like to dive into that
scenario
i'd like to dive into that have true
love for a child but then also
be almost selfish enough to go but i but
i bet i got a chance to do that
what i was put here to do i got a chance
to do something no one else has ever
done
that's a it's it's a great a great
challenge right there
well one thing that comes across very
early in the book
um and even in the things that you are
saying
um about these movies is that
you know this existence that you have
which is
really quite a lot of duality and
you're really um touching both sides of
the hole
a lot you know and um
i'm very curious about that if this is
something learned is this something you
learned from your parents because
clearly that was pretty um love hate at
times and
and um dramatic as they were remarried
each other three times they married each
other three times
divorced twice to each other so
is this something that you learn from
them or do you
feel as though this is something in your
soul
that you just have to touch both sides
um a little bit of both probably more
the second
hmm but i haven't thought about it until
now but yeah the extremes
it has something to do with this because
yeah my mom and dad are an example of
extremes
pushed by married three times all right
buddy by sheer mathematics what ended up
well the love one if you call that love
hate hate got twice and loved one
got three three to two hate you lose now
do you need to have five battles
a lot of endurance they had a lot of
endurance for the lesson
they did but also here's
here's where my parents were that maybe
subconsciously i i noticed because i
never consciously noticed
i'm like they didn't see it as extreme
they they like
resilience is probably the top thing
that was ingrained in us
and in me as as a kid and boy they're an
example my mom and dad are an example of
it
i mean how are you venture to go how
much was that
one of those how much of those divorces
about just wanting to have another
honeymoon
it's kind of exciting when you think
about it like that i mean
because they say oh yeah yeah we need
some you know what dolly part and recent
say
what's what's what's the great thing
about our marriage how it lasts
we got time away from each other and we
love coming back
i didn't know they were divorced i
thought mom was on extended vacations in
navarre beach florida
well this is where your wife is
obviously playing a huge role to tell
you
um you need to go
yes and then she she'll know so like i
said sometimes before i know
um and you know we all
yeah we so yeah camilla and try to
practice as well we just
don't want to go we don't want to go as
far as saying hey let's get divorced and
get remarried again hang on
let's not go that far but my mom and dad
loved
my mom's 88 with us now to this day
if a conversation like this is going
well for 30 minutes she starts getting
antsy
she's gotta throw a wrench in here
somewhere come on this as it's sitting
up
come on it makes you and you're like i'm
staying
nothing you hate worse than an easy
going moment
she's still but that's also why she's so
healthy at 88 she
chooses has always chosen the path
of most resistance i mean she's the one
that
that society's beat two types of cancer
on aspirin
she's the one that goes and and like can
get a root canal
and won't take even gas and says like
come on
bring it on and i'm like i don't want
that much
pain she's just like do it i don't want
a pain pill i don't want gas
nothing get it the doctors are going i'm
telling you man this is gonna she's like
do it this is that this is that lady
this is
this is a this is a mother that you know
when i had tubes in my ears
as a child they would have to get them
removed you could either
surgically get them removed which you
either they don't know if they put you
under because i never did it that way
but it was all it was like it was about
you know a two thousand dollar job to
get the tubes
or you could sit there in the chair and
the doctor could reach in with tweezers
and boom
pull them and your eardrum just goes and
it hurts like a
earthquake but it only cost three
hundred dollars
and so on the way drive down there every
time she black
if you do the one where you sit in the
chair and you just let him pull him out
it'll hurt more but we'll get some tc by
tcby yogurt on the way out
i'd be like i'm in let's do it
but i got my yogurt on the way home this
is for the sprinkles honey
ah so you know there there were extremes
but
you know here's another thing that's
inherent in this conversation about
their relationship that maybe i
i i did notice forgiveness
i forgive you now let's move on
let's carry on see how much see we can
see if we can stay married a while on
her
years later can't do it damn well
can't live with you again
oh [ __ ] i miss you now you miss me yeah
come on let's do this again i forgive
you come on
that's that's how they and that was in
motion that was not
neither one of them went away and like
in the divorces they were not
woe be me i didn't notice a different in
their moods i didn't know a difference
in their moods i didn't notice they were
un
happy or going through a tough time and
hell i'm not even sure they were
just kind of say lovey this let's roll
with it let's do we got to do
so yeah there was great duality
and and great dynamics that i grew up
seeing
um and then on the second part it is
something that
that that i lean into and it's that
paradox that i keep bringing up
i think that's where i think that's
where it
is actually not the contradiction but
the paradox they both are true
and instead of or um
[Music]
instead of what's the it there it's
where it is what's it
it that the the the
the closest we can get to that
ta-da ah
meaning i'm talking about what we see is
contradict sir we talked about selfish
self less
we talked and where are the
the coolest prophets what did they have
they had where the best decision for the
eye
was the best decision for the we
what is i would say my definition of
heaven if there is a heaven what i hope
it would be
and what is it on earth where what you
want
is actually what you need and what you
need
is actually what you want think about
that if we
if what we desired
and just lustfully want it
was also what was the best for us
there's a spot where those two meet
really i think can be difficult or maybe
it's just too simple
to get to the maybe it's too simple to
for us to even give enough credit but
that's the place
that i want to chase down i'm sure as
heck not there
you know but boy that place i'm like
that's the honey hole
that's well
that's where you you know this makes me
think of this whole
dynamic of the of like judgment and
denial
um something i've been working with a
lot lately is this you know what the
things that i
judge representing the things that i'm
denying in myself
and so say that you want something if
you can sort of
feed that urge you can either appease it
and learn where you f the balance is for
you
or it just shifts your trajectory right
you either come back for you
either way you're learning and you're
you are
um becoming more whole by scratching the
itch
yes yes and
and i think even more so is going or
even to
jump on the back side of what you just
said which is
a life full of scratching your itches is
as good as it gets
that's it and if we can find some or to
have new itches we don't want to have
the same itch all the time because
that's like
why do i keep doing the same damn thing
but we can have a little bit of
evolution
and as we get a little bit better and we
you know hat is what happens when you
get we
we reach a goal
you don't go oh i did it done
well here comes 50 here comes 100 new
challenges
i got 100 new itches you know which one
do i or or that
itch the original itch became a bigger
edge because you got to the next level
and you're like wow and i think the idea
that most of it i have that
oh once you scratch the itch then it's
over
or once you've found your frequency
you're in the zone
ah i got it
[Music]
that won't go away too if you have any
ambition
that one's going away look i admire
people that go
no man i got my frequency i don't want
any more or less i'm staying right here
i'm like
man really okay well bravo
and they can be like that but i'm not
one of those people i'm like well what's
next
yeah what's war what does more mean how
much is it quantity how much is equality
um what is the measure what's my
measurement of
my currency am i filling my bank account
and my soul's account
you know um so i'm always wanting to
go and it's it's it but i but i'm
learning that
i call it i call it chasing yet
we're never getting there and if we
realize you never it's never done
it's not done life's a verb
and if we can scratch our edges all the
way and just keep going
i was brave enough to go get the poison
ivy again or get a new itch whatever
that is or and and i'm
and i'm and i'm courageous enough to go
hang on i'm going to scratch that thing
woke me up again last night and then go
why
that's what we're going to do until
we're out until we're gone
and that's as good as it gets we can say
okay it's the game
that the whistle doesn't blow until i'm
out of here
and they say here's your eulogy
you know i mean i i because we love our
immediate gratification
we want to know and have it all right
now
this is not you again that taught out
moment i don't think is exists
the joy's in the journey to me this is
the heart
in my mind because again we we all see
life through our own personal lens
like that's what this book is to me when
i think of that con
that conversation that that what you
just said
is green lights it is intuition
it is how do you know where to go next
that to me
that that was that's your book right
there green light how do you know where
to go and when to go there
heard okay yeah and
obviously so many times we don't know um
i talk in the book a lot about process
of elimination
to put us you know if you get rid of
things that don't feed us that aren't
true
for us you will end up mathematically
more options in front of us that are
true to ourselves
but also um an underutilized one that
that that
i forget to bring up and nobody ever
really else brings up
is sometimes it's about just
you got a and b just pick one and commit
to it
just pick one though because how many
times we look around and go hey
b i'm not sure well and all of a sudden
you look up and it's years later and
you're still going hey you're b
i'm not sure why you're like oh geez the
world changed it's not even a or b
anymore if you just picked one pick the
lame
you know to use to use a term that calls
back to
it's a green light and and what and what
you do is like
pick a lane man and go just go online i
don't know if it's the right one
okay good but drive go commit to it
because a lot of times it's not even
about the choice as much as it's like
well just pick one
really not going to matter the
difference in the truth again the
contradiction and that you
seem and the choices is not really such
a contradiction
just pick one commit to it you find out
along the way
it's um uh you said once the the
the the dialogue you have to have the
dialogue to have the monologue
and that kind of that kind of thing that
you said that's what i think of
because it's how do you know where to go
and sometimes
you just you have to set that beacon way
out there it's like
follow the lights way out there and it
doesn't really matter if you wander
six lanes that way or you know detour
through
you know santa fe new mexico you're
you're headed to the coast
if you can just go well it's
north south east or west let me just
pick one of those
and whatever that entails about in our
course direction
in life just pick that and then give
yourself like say
give yourself 16 lanes with which to
swerve all over in
take the exits the feeder roads
everything just
and if you're heading that direction
then you can forget about and not worry
about the fact that
oh i'm not going the opposite way okay
good as long as i just keep going in
this direction
towards that star that's i'll find out
here along the way
it's sort of a safety net you know i
want to hear what your best and worst
detours ever been what's your best and
worst
beer like when you veered way too far
one direction or way too far the other
right what was the
what was the best one that you led you
like got you it like
it was like going warp speed you got nos
for a second when you made this decision
and then the other one that you go well
you know
it was a bit of a [ __ ] storm but i
learned a lot yeah okay
um well let me say this after i took
i took a couple years off i'm gonna give
you one that's on career both these had
to do with
career times but i took about two years
off not because i wanted to because i
wasn't getting the offer of the movies i
wanted to do and i wasn't gonna do what
i was doing
which was the rom-coms at that time so i
said i'm going to wait for the
dramatic fair that i want to come in
front of me and i didn't know if it
would well two years later
after not working at all in hollywood
getting no offers they did come
and boy when they did i was salivating
man
i mean my things came out i was like oh
now because i remember back in 96 after
time to kill the world opened up and i
was like whoa
i'm not sure what i want to do here for
the first time i can do what i want
well this time when this happened and
now all of a sudden it opened up and i
was able to start doing what i wanted i
was like oh no
i'm steering this ship i know what the
hell i want to do
i'm going to do with this and i want
that and i want that that clarity
and then giving myself the ownership to
say and look myself in the mirror and go
you know and you know
don't ask anybody else's advice you know
mcconaughey just do it
they've given me myself that that the
the leverage to have that confidence and
just say
go for the experience and i remember
saying because i chose a lot of films
that weren't necessarily paydays
um but i remember writing right now
[ __ ] the box i'm going for the
experience all right
and doing that putting my head down
not even thinking about the result going
i'm getting i'm not entering the clay
man i'm not here we i'm tasting this all
of a sudden what happens
those results start coming in trophies
and accolades i'm like oh yeah
okay cool thank you yeah that was
taking that ownership um was a big sort
of
oh really owning that with extreme
confidence and even obsession
to give myself the right and mind you to
have a family and a wife that also gave
me the right to go
yes be obsessed
[Music]
um was a courageous move that really
paid off for me now let me give you a
little
one where a little courageous great new
bright idea did not work out so well
yes so
i am in uh going through a period of my
career early early earlier in my career
before time kill all that but i'm out in
hollywood
and i'm going through a period of about
eight months where i'm i'm i'm
i'm get going and i'm auditioning for a
role i get a call back but then i don't
get another call back i'm just not
landing parts and every time i leave
every audition i'm like
you kind of left something in the back
man you kind of you know when you come
out and you feel like yeah i gave you 85
what i left 15 or 10 on the floor damn
it why did i take that risk there was
that moment i could have taken advantage
of
and as soon as i thought oh well should
i what i could it was gone
that fence i kept coming out of those
things going damn it well at this time
was the first time that someone started
introduced to me what acting was
now i'd never taken acting lessons so
united is when you have to learn
something for the first time that you
already have instincts for
there's a there's an awkward period
where you're getting
literally heady about something that you
through your ignorance
and instincts before we're just you're
built for it
and now you want me to understand the
minutia how it works
you know and so when you're learning
that there's a passage you know that's
usually pretty complicated
uh for sports you know a new defensive
coordinator comes in
you know you want to you're going to
learn a new defensive package that first
year when a football team has to do dc
probably
they're not going to be very good
defense because they're out there
thinking about it now the next year
after they've been in the system
oh i understand the playbook i've had
the reps now it's instinctual and i'm a
better player than i was
when i was only off of going off of
innate instinctual ability
yeah well i get cast in this role in
this movie
no audition come in one day roll
it's just you're playing this drug
runner on the mexican border in texas
and the coyote is going to bring the
drugs over and
and they think you're going to pay them
but you don't pay them because you
you shoot them all and steal the drugs
and go that's that's the byline for the
scene well i get this idea and i go hey
you know i haven't i've been
being kind of tight lately i'm kind of
heady i'm not getting auditions i need
to go back and act
the way i did when i first began in days
confused when
i had never taken an acting class when
three lines turned into three weeks work
because i knew my man
and i just showed up in scenes and said
and did what my man would do
yeah i need to go back there when there
wasn't a script
i'm a naturalist i'm an improver
right idea right so
i decide on this script for this movie
that i've just been offered this role is
that
drug runner it that i'm not going to
read the script
not only am i not going to read the
script i'm not going to read the scene
i just need to know the scenario i need
to know my man and i'll do and say what
my man
would do
great idea right yep everything's full
going ahead this is a great idea this is
the new you matthew this is the way to
do it this is who you are
i sure i'm awesome i'm
on my mark the other actors are there
i'm not even talking to them because hey
they're the coyotes that i'm about to
kill take them from i'm just there i'm
going to do what my man would do
bring it on we're about to shoot the
take
i have not read the script i've not read
the scene the production
assistant walks by and says mr
mcconaughey would you like some sides
you know that miniature version of your
of your scene that day well evidently i
had a little insecurity about my plan
because i said
yeah let me see the side so i grab them
and write for the take i go
let me have a peek at him because you
know what if it's written well
it'll be like well obviously that's what
i was going to say that's what i was
going to do and if it's not written well
i'll just do
what my man would do which was my
original plan well i open these sites
i'm on my mark about to shoot the scene
i open these sizes i look at page one
or page two
page three page four
and i remember saying to everyone and no
one in particular
uh can i get 12 minutes my thinking was
12 minutes would be not long enough time
to
be inconsiderate to the crew
but it might also be enough time for me
to learn and memorize a four-page
monologue
in spanish oh god guys hey i took
spanish for one semester in the 11th
grade
holy [ __ ] oh my gosh this bead of sweat
comes up on the back of my neck
and i go walk off for 12 minutes and i
don't let anyone know
that i'm you know um weeding in my pants
here going what in
the hell oh my god i came back into the
scene i've never watched the movie i
don't know what i did
but i was so damn embarrassed
that i was not prepared that that day is
where i learned the lesson no no no no
no
but boy you prepare so you can have the
freedom
you put in the work so you can play
and uh the preparation since that day
for me and my career has been one of my
greatest
strengths the amount of time i'll
prepare the amount of time i'll go over
my playbook
the confidence to come in and the
ownership of my man as i call them
to be able to call audibles on the set
with whatever anybody gives me because
i'm that prepared
and i learned it the hard way that day
wow what an incredible story
it actually leads perfectly into
something i'm
i'm curious if you will go to this space
or not
if you're willing um but you've
mentioned the word a couple times in
this interview and i thought actually
before
before this was something that i wanted
to ask you um and so i thought it was
kind of a
sign that you had mentioned this word a
couple of times for me to ask it but
in preparation in the light of
preparation
i'm curious if you can enter this space
where
you would be able to
basically wing your eulogy
basically wing your eulogy my eulogy
yeah go
for it like whatever reverse
engineer your life from the end and and
yeah
yeah yeah boy i tell you what he's sure
how do you want to be remembered
he sure did revere fatherhood and you
know what he was a damn good father
he uh he sure did take risk damn he had
a good sense of humor he never had
he actually didn't know how to half-ass
something
boy not knowing what would happen
if he took a cert if he took risk bugged
him a heck of a lot more than it did to
taking the risk of failing
man you don't see many people that
that actually start giggling so so soon
after they step in [ __ ] do you
damn he'd start giggling right away
because i remember him saying
well if i don't giggle and i get ticked
off
it doesn't mean if i get ticked off
instead of giggling
it doesn't mean i didn't step in the
[ __ ] i still stepped in the [ __ ]
so let's start giggling quicker um
he was at home at the home in the world
you know what he'd love to go to a place
and say
whatever it is whether it was camping
out or in the deserts of mali or in the
shangri-la
he liked to go and go
stay here until he believed he could
live here have try to create
relationships
friendships find the love of
his life where you can go are they a
friend are they someone that he
that he cared about that he could spend
the rest of their life being friends
with
or married to or father too um
and then you know what else he did a lot
of guys
hey where that relationship he worked on
more than any
was the one with himself
and
that's why that's why he was friends
with me
and that's that last part would be if
that was
there's a charles lawton had this quote
i said my oscar speech and my teacher
my great late teacher penny allen used
to say it to me
her husband always say well if you got
god in your life if you got god then you
got a friend
and that friend is you
so yeah that's that's that was my my
my eulogy wrap that's awesome
that's you living it you're doing it
trying to you know today as you know
it's constant maintenance as we've been
talking about this whole time um
yeah you know i i i it's
it's it's sometimes
you know things are when things are
going
well i mean i know in my own life
sometimes you'll have a i have anyway
you know non-deserving complex like wait
why me
why this um and
because i actually like even to this day
at 51
with whatever i've accomplished and
success i've had
i like i'd rather feel like the underdog
i don't even if i'm number one on the
call sheet or
first in line i i want i like
just going on and maybe that's going to
remind us of no it's it's fleeting it's
bleeding you still got to stay on
stay on the sniff man stay on it you
know keep working keep breaking the
sweat on that whatever that is
um i do like that position of the
underdog at least especially in
a mentality and when i was talking about
earlier definition of humility
i'm still i've learned and i'm still
learning how to
when if i'm consider myself an underdog
and when
[Music]
to own the fact that i won even though i
was an underdog
the humility it'll be it's gonna be real
interesting to see what's what's coming
up
up next you know i've got i got three
children
family and camille and i are doing well
my mom's with us she's 88
brothers still close to them um
you know how many new goals well i have
coming up
from now i'm i'm not sure because a lot
of it
as you know as you go through life it's
not necessarily about
always about getting a new goal it's
about well how do i let the roots go
wider and deeper within the one
that i'm in the midst of achieving
totally
um but
i just hope there's still enough out
there and it seems that there is
enough in reality to keep getting off to
and i think there is what's your next
green light my next green light
friday night oh fun yeah i agree
with my favorite day of the week i mean
i still get excited about friday nights
like i did when i was
16 in high school friday night i'm still
so friday nights when we let the
kids stay asleep as they want come on
let's get it on on friday night um
and uh yeah hanging with the family and
doing whatever we do and getting out the
ice cream and watching movies and
everything else
on a friday night is there drinks on
friday night
you damn right there's drinks on friday
night what drink do you drink
well i'll start off with a little
tequila and i'll end up with a little
long branch bourbon
friday sounds like you got a fun friday
night ahead of you friday night
like i like it when friday nights merge
into saturday mornings
oh that's possible in the house
does that happen at home with just with
camilla with your mom with the kids
we got enough room right here where
after 12 we can get the drums out and
camilla and i can
shin dig it up does she play does she
play or sing or anything
no we did like
dance more dancing i'll be on the drums
did she drink the bourbon and the uh and
the tequila with you
she does i love love i can tell you're
in love it's so beautiful
maybe that's it maybe that's maybe
that's uh maybe that's
that's the space we're all meant to find
you're a really impressive human
you you get it you you as much as i mean
this is the humility that you
said you want to have you you get it i
mean i'm just telling you i'm reflecting
that back to you
you do thank you for sharing that and
being the storyteller
well enjoy your friday night thank you
so much thank you
enjoyed talking to you nice to meet you
yeah too it's really nice to meet you
all right yo appreciate it thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button